ou pas vu booba sur ces parties au liban
pourquoi est ce qu'on a vu booba ce
clash avec siri l'assistant vocal de son
iphone oui tu t'es tu temps brouillé et
comprend série qui la met en musique de
monde
ta mère tu t'es tu te fais des équipes
comme ça est sur une série non tu fais
tu fais tu fais des quiches sur un star
pour garder un peu sur nesta booba ou
pas ah ben oui ma fille regarde top-10
il faut alors est ce qu'on a vu booba
charrier le rappeur la fouine sur son
nouveau de récits mort oui
ouais regardez regardez ils m'ont dit tu
es ou dans un magasin de basket
j'aurais dit non je suis dans mon
dressing gagnant ils m'ont dit t'es où
nous avons besoin de basket blagueur
[Rires]
sa fille en même temps étant des perches
ça va mieux avec lui il a au bled et
orienter max et les eaux calmes
est ce qu'on a vu ce que la vue les
chroniqueurs de tpb se la péter en
reprenant les tubes de bubba ho oui
alors compte un star c'était chaud
regardez regardez regardez si la marée
noire mauvais la bague au doigt de loi
l'ama drina voudrait la bague au doigt
j'ai fait des caddies pour la pièce
[Applaudissements]
voici je t'envoie c'est franchement non
savoir vous a bien aimé vous abonner
truffé connaissez vous pas vous aimez ou
par la musique va bien je donne tu
prends 20 de bois qu'on oui en fait
c'est vraiment dommage parce que quand
quelqu'un comme lui ou toi vous
réussissez quelqu'un qui sort de la rue
a réussi et qui est autant à chaque fois
de mauvais oeil pourquoi ne pas prier
pour qu'ils réussissent linverse qu
compris pour qu'il réussisse dans un
seau russie comme je sais vous vengez
pas la force mais c'est un message que
je veux faire passer pour on a la chance
d'avoir un artiste comme ça et il faut
plutôt je vous préfère moi prier pour
lui qui réussit alors vous pouvez poser
toutes les questions
il va y répondre dans un instant booba
il ya un truc aussi que j'ai découvert
c'est était venu sur la star ac ou par
l'époque j'étais venue de la star ac est
ce que tu te rappelles avec kit avait
chanté son nom
cynthia et cynthia regarde c'est pas vu
grandir j'ai toujours osé poser mettrai
sur la rue
tu te connectes en fait refusé la luxure
mois à l'usure peut n'être jamais cru
même quand les boules m cuisine moi je
devenir se jouera du second semestre
gommer
je vais recruter
je regarde regarde les télé crochets
tout ça se voit et c'est tout pas du
tout non pas du tout a déjà proposé de
faire partie d'un des membres du jury ou
non à un moment j'avais entendu un truc
comme quand il voulait peut-être que tu
sois dans le jury de the voice site ont
ils sont même pas approché tu l'aurais
pas fait non sinon vous faire faire ma
propre émission comme ça ouais c'est ça
donne un peu de fraîcheur
ouais t'as des projets de démission
comme ça peut-être nous en parler non ma
mois talât week-end
non mais ce que j'aime avec booba c'est
son parcours parfois compliqué il est
tombé il s'est relevé élevé seule par sa
mère je trouve que c'est un parcours en
un poignant ce que j'aime avec aussi
booba c'est le fait que quand quelqu'un
réussit qu'ils aident les autres
inconnus à réussir c'est très rarement
parler hockey au calme à valence et
gradient nice car ou encore des matchs d
je trouve que c'est rare et c'est là on
va parler de dixon thaler parce que ça
c'est dit que c'est très fort vous dit
très très fort est ce qu'on a vu booba
offrir vingt mille euros à son comble à
son cambrioleur pour qu'ils lui rendre
ses affaires tu t'es fait cambrioler ttt
temps là sera totale moi ça va c'est sur
l'ordinateur
ouais voilà c'est ça son tout ça va y
avait des sons tout ça donc en garde et
aux montres
regardez ce que booba avait écrit aux
cambrioleurs voilà un jeu 20000 euros à
celui ou celle qui me rapportera mon
laptop et dm mois d'un faucon pour ana
avoila et regarder en fait ce que tu as
fait c'est que tu a filmé la scène en
rentrant chez toi
2-1 o'brien
[Musique]
c'est pas beau c'est pas beau est ce
qu'on a vu booba s'embrouiller avec son
fils pour une sombre histoire de bananes
oui aussi
c'est aussi très drôle à l'est du rhône
ont commencé à se tourner d'abord se
tourner mais c'est vraiment une pince
doigts mais partagent mon prêt le
partage non c'est un gage de papa dans
ses bagages la donne
[Applaudissements]